bonjour aujourd'hui une très courte
vidéo juste pour vous faire une petite
annonce est-ce que vous allez devinez de
quoi il s'agit
alors oui vous avez évidemment deviné il
s'est inscrit par tout dans le décor
j'ai écrit un livre s'appelle comprendre
le monde avec la pop culture ça
ressemble évidemment au format classique
de sociologique que je fais sur la
chaîne où je parle à la fois de sciences
sociales et culture geek je suis très
très fier de vous le présenter il est
sorti hier en librairie ça fait à peu
près deux ans que je travaille dessus
maintenant c'est mon tout premier livre
et je suis vraiment super content du
résultat il ya des illustrations signées
grégoire jk il a fait un super travail
je vous montre un petit peu là à quoi
cela peut ressembler la mise en page est
super cool voilà le petit chapitre sur
le sien aux anneaux si jamais vous avez
peur des redites sachez que tous les
thèmes que j'aborde dans le livre sont
des choses que je n'ai absolument pas
traité dans les vidéos sociologique et
donc du coup c'est absolument du neuf il
y aura pas de redites avec ce que j'ai
pu faire sur la chaîne pour jusqu'à
maintenant même si évidemment il les
petites choses qui peuvent se recouper
mais c'est toujours en tout cas fait
avec un angle et une façon de traiter
complètement nouvelle alors je sais pas
si on voit bien je mets la table des
matières il est composé de neuf
chapitres le principe c'est que pour
chaque chapitre je prends une oeuvre de
la pop culture et j'essaie d'avoir un
projet particulier de tirer les fils sur
ce que ça peut nous apprendre qu'on a un
chapitre sur harry potter en chapitres
sur le seigneur des anneaux au chapitre
sur star trek on a un chapitre également
sur shrek que ce beaucoup aimé écrire
regardez l'illustration est tout
simplement génial alors oui pour les
illustrations il a souvent fallu qu'on
s'arrange un petit peu parce que en
raison des droits d'auteur il y avait
certains personnages copyright et qu'on
n'avait pas le droit d'utiliser un tel
cas des super héros notamment batman
superman spiderman et cetera dont je
parle dans le livre est bon grégoire
gicquel a été ultra inventif il a
toujours trouvé une façon de représenter
quand même les personnages de façon tout
à fait évocatrice fins morceaux ses
illustrations vraiment sympa j'aborde
des thèmes qui sont parfois un peu plus
large que ce que je peux faire sur la
chaîne puisque je parle pas uniquement
de sociologie je parle aussi d'histoire
je parle de science politique parle
d'économie aussi j'ai tout un chapitre
notamment sur star trek ou sur les
prophéties où j'ai un angle beaucoup
plus économique là dessus mais l'idée
c'est toujours d'essayer de décoder le
monde 2 à travers les oeuvres de fiction
dont essayer de voir ce que ça peut nous
apprendre du monde réel et d'essayer
d'apprendre avec des trucs fun des trucs
de la culture pop avec une tuerie geek
est en tout cas si vous pensez que ça
peut vous plaire n'hésitez pas à
l'acheter à l'offrir à vos proches il
est disponible un peu partout évidemment
si vous pouvez l'acheter dans une petite
librairie plutôt que sur amazon c'est
mieux mais évidemment vous faites comme
vous le pouvez voilà il y en a souvent
qu'ils me demandent comment ils peuvent
me soutenir c'est vrai que moi je
monétise pas même une vidéo j'ai pas de
tipis j'ai pas de gêne aucune plateforme
comme ça mais si le coeur vous en dit le
livre vient de sortir et les sorties
hier c'est super content de pouvoir
enfin le tenir dans mes mains après
avoir travaillé dessus autant de temps
et bien j'espère que vous aurez autant
de plaisir à lire que moi j'ai eu à
l'écrire c'est aussi un peu ça qui
explique que ces derniers temps j'avais
fait un peu moins de vidéos sur la
chaîne j'ai déjà un travail à plein
temps donc du coup la chaîne youtube ce
le fait à côté sur le temps qui me reste
hélas le temps que j'avais été beaucoup
utilisé pour la rédaction du bouquin
mais comme vous avez pu le voir
maintenant que le bouquin est sorti de
reprise d'activité un peu plus régulière
sur youtube et j'ai bien l'intention de
continuer comme ça donc restez connecté
il ya encore plein de contenus qui va
arriver évidemment dans les jours et les
mois à venir maintenant petites annonces
pour les parisiens qui serait disponible
mardi prochain je serai en dédicace du
coup au 15 bis la librairie de gibert
joseph et venez nombreux il ya un agent
facebook je vais m haies en description
venez je ferai des dédicaces on peut
discuter parler de sociologie de pop
culture ce que vous voulez normalement
ça devrait être bonne ambiance ramener
des copains là on n'a pas beaucoup
d'inscrits pour l'instant sur facebook
en même temps je n'allais pas encore
vraiment beaucoup parler venez nombreux
n'hésitez pas à prendre le livre pour
vous pour un cadeau pour les gens que
vous aimez vous les gens que vous
n'aimez pas aussi si vous voulez moi je
vous fais des gros bisous on se retrouve
très vite ciao
[Musique]
il
et